else clay following up on that you  mentioned it was championship or bust  you know what it takes to win a title  with you coming back and with james  coming back do you feel like this team  has the ingredients to win a title this  year oh yeah it's 15-2 that's a great  indicator of and our defense  i think is top three in the league as  well as our offense  and i'm not even out there yet think  about that  really think about that  i'm more motivated than ever as well and  um  i want a championship so bad  more than anything  draymond talked today about  what's driving him and you know part of  it is the haters and the doubters and  stuff  is that part of your deal too yeah  no question  no question i wanted to be on that top i  wanted some recognition i didn't get it  and that's fine no you get recognition  you'll win so  i just want to go win again